التوتر في هذه المنطقه مازال سائدا حيث
دوت صفرات الانذار منذ صباح هذا اليوم
بدايه في بلده المناره في الجليل الاعلى
ثم دوت في ست بلدات مختلفه في اصبع الجليل
لاسما في يفتاح التي تكرر فيها دوي صفرات
الانذار في اوقات متباعده وذلك بعد ما
كانت صفرات ال قد دوت عده مرات متتاليه
اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي بعدها ان تتالي دوي
صفرات الانذار جاء نتيجه لخطا ولكن الثابت
هو دوي صفارات الانذار مره على الاقل في
يفتاح ومره في المناره وهذا يشير الى وجود
خطر اطلاق صواريخ باتجاه هذه المنطقه وهو
ما دفع الجيش الاسرائيلي لدعوه السكان في
هذه المنطقه للابتعاد عن المناطق الحدوديه
لاسما الواصله ما بين المناره ويفتاح هذه
المناطق القريبه جدا من الحدود مع لبنان
في الجليل الاعلى واصبع الجليل ووجهت
الجبهه الداخليه توجيهات
لسكان في المنطقه من تبقى منهم على الاقل
لاتخاذ اجراءات امنيه في ظل تكرر وتكرار
اطلاق الصواريخ من من الجانب اللبناني
باتجاه البلدات الاسرائيليه شماليه
اسرائيل على امتداد هذه الحدود من
المنطقه الواقعه في اصبع الجليل باتجاه
الجليل الغربي هذه المناطق ايضا كانت قد
تعرضت لاطلاق عده صواريخ خلال هذه الليله
اعلن عنها الجيش الاسرائيلي لاسما في كل
من مزارع شبعه وشتوى لكن اخر المعلومات
التي تحدثت عنها وسائل الاعلام
الاسرائيليه هو اصابه مستودع في منطقه يير
اون الواقعه في الجليل الاعلى بعد اطلاق
صاروخ مضاد ل الدروع باتجاه هذه المنطقه
وهو مستودع يحتوي على جرارات وفقا لوسائل
الاعلام الاسرائيليه في اخر معطياتها دون
الحديث عن ذلك حتى اللحظه من جانب الجيش
الاسرائيلي ولكن ايضا المتحدث باسم الجيش
الاسرائيلي يتحدث عن هذه الجبهه ويؤكد ان
الجيش الاسرائيلي يخوض ما وصفه بالقتال
المكثف على هذه الجبهه وهو من جهه يهاجم
مواقع حزب الله في الداخل اللبناني كما
ايضا خطوط داد في سوريا وتحدث عن ارقام
لهذه الاستهدافات قال ان الجيش الاسرائيلي
حتى يوم امس استهدف
3400 هدف كما وصفه لحزب الله من بينها
مستودعات للذخيره وكذلك مواقع ومراكز
عسكريه وادى الى مقتل ايضا 200 من عناصر
حزب الله وفقا لبيان الجيش الاسرائيلي
وهذا ياتي ايضا بالتزامن مع الحديث عن
ضروره اعاده السكان الى هذه المنطقه بامان
وفقا ل بيان الجيش من الجليل الاعلى مراسل
الجزيره حسن مسعود شكرا جزيلا لك